so last week we talked about democratic
socialism versus social democracy and I
talked to you about how especially since
Alexandria Acacio cortezes win in New
York there has been sort of more and
more confusion as to what is democratic
socialism versus what is social
democracy and I did a story explaining
the difference democratic socialism is
actually socialism wants to remove
capitalism and replace it with
socialized ownership of the means of
production at least originally although
now there are people who say well
there's still democratic socialists but
they don't actually want that which
makes me question whether they're
actually democratic socialists at this
point and then on the other hand we
talked about social democracy which is a
progressive movement that wants to work
within a market economy within
capitalism and make it more of what I
call a socially guided market economy
and the difference is massive and the
confusion between these two systems is
very very problematic and the top
response that I got from people in the
audience was I mean of course other than
trolling was what's your position David
and I've mentioned before that I'm not a
socialist I'm a Social Democrat in the
sort of Nordic or Swedish tradition and
today I'm going to explain to you why I
am NOT a socialist and I'm happy to do
this it's something that's been an area
of study for me since undergraduate and
even even including in graduate school
and I'm gonna start sort of at the end
and then we'll walk through it
fundamentally I'm not a socialist
because I want an egalitarian free
self-determining Society and that type
of society will not emerge from
authoritarian apparatus and what that
means is that at the national level
socialist and communist structures are
fundamentally authoritarian and at scale
enacting socialism or communism becomes
authoritarian and a top example is
Venezuela let's assume in good faith
that the Shabbos Maduro goal was a truly
egalitarian free thriving society I
don't know if it was but let's be
charitable
right and they really did want that as
the end goal when you put aside the
populist collectivist rhetoric of that
regime the Venezuelan regime is an
authoritarian imposition of government
without all sorts of freedoms lacking in
press freedom lacking in judicial
freedom it's a long list and I'm opposed
to it and whatever their intern
intentions were their imposition of
those intentions in this authoritarian
way has led to absolute disaster and
some socialists Leninists will say that
the opposition to the Venezuelan regime
is American astroturf or that the
replacement to Maduro might be worse
step back for a second an authoritarian
apparatus will not lead to an
egalitarian self-determining society
period but before we get to all of the
conclusions we need to talk about what
we mean when we say socialism or
communism
when did it start what does it actually
mean so for our conversation today when
I talk about socialism I'm talking about
modern socialism and communism in the
tradition of the 19th century and if you
go back to our socialism has never
worked debunked video we mentioned older
societies and sort of collectivist
iterations of economic arrangements but
for today we're talking about modern
socialist theory and that dates back
roughly to about the 1800s and there are
three main lines of socialist theory
almost no one who likes to talk about
socialism on the internet actually knows
about this stuff this is really
important as the nuts-and-bolts first
you had the utopians in the 19th century
these are people like Sen C Mon Fourier
and Owen and their idea was that there
would be the development of these
collectivist egalitarian sort of perfect
as the name utopian implies societies
sometimes in isolated enclaves and they
would eventually spread and I actually
do believe that individually they can
work but once you say this is the system
for the country
it becomes authoritarian in its
implementation you'll develop conflicts
between these utopian enclaves but as
usual there was some good stuff proposed
there okay their Theory applied to an
individual company or a commune or a
village it's actually a pretty good idea
I've just not seen evidence that utopian
Theory can apply to a country of 300
million for example but I'm willing to
have my mind changed after the utopians
came the anarchists the sort of second
wave second line of socialists and the
main thing with the anarchist was that
government is the problem they were
actually a lot like the more extreme
libertarians of today for different
reasons than libertarianism the
anarchist socialist saw the government
mostly as an apparatus that reinforces
the status quo of class divisions
bourgeoisie versus proletariat or today
we could say corporate versus individual
interests or elites versus everybody
else and libertarians of course oppose
government for different reasons but
there was actually a similarity there
and that also doesn't appeal to me as
most people know I'm against this on
principle I think that the government
does have a role to play but that being
said the anarchists had some valid
critiques governments often do become
pillars of support for corporate rule
they do reinforce the status quo they do
reinforce power structures I've seen no
evidence that eliminating the government
is the solution in the way that the
anarcho socialists or the libertarians
believed super-interesting that even
though now libertarians and socialists
are mostly diametrically opposed some of
the original strains of socialist
thought had a lot in common with
libertarianism they agree they don't
want central government because it's
oppressive and tyrannical but for
different reasons and then after the
utopians and after the anarchists you
get to what are now the most common
versions of socialism after utopianism
and anarchism came Marxist Leninist it
together or Marxism and then Leninism
they're not actually the same thing and
they're once again there is stuff of
value if people could realize that many
of the critiques made by socialism are
actually really good we'd be much better
off some of the solutions they proposed
have only elements of good ideas and in
Marxism its the labor theory of value
extraordinarily brilliant analysis of
how capitalism works which basically
pointed out that you have fixed costs
like if you're gonna make a product if
you're gonna make computers for example
you've got your fixed material costs
you've got the factory you need to buy
the semiconductors all of that stuff and
then you bring in workers and you pay
them something with the idea that they
add more than that to the total value
and that's surplus value you might have
in a hundred dollar computer fifty
dollars of parts and then fifty dollars
of added value if you can pay the worker
thirty dollars to add fifty dollars of
value you've created twenty dollars of
surplus value this is a great analysis
this is this is an absolutely accurate
analysis the problem is I don't believe
the ultimate solution to that
identification is the end stage of
capitalism with a Marxist revolution
that's not what I see is the long term
solution
so again utopianism i don't think it
would work at the country level but for
individual companies or communes i think
it's actually a great idea to organize
co-ops and and shared ownership great
that has worked we can apply it to
healthcare we can apply to education i
don't see that as the solution to all of
society anarchism skeptical of
government government has become a tool
of the elites in many ways we see it in
the united states with democrats and
republicans using government as a way to
maintain the status quo it's a good
critique I disagree that eliminating
government is the solution and so what
previously had been sort of a cohesive
movement but with different approaches
utopianism anarchism Marxism Leninism
eventually what we saw around the time
of Lenin was a split between actual
socialists and those who went in the
direction of social democracy and I
believe that there are a number of
reasons why social democracy is the way
forward and socialism is not and in
explaining this to you you'll identify
many right-wing arguments against
socialism which I actually don't think
are good ones and this gets to one of my
fundamental opposition's to socialism's
view of the distributions of outcomes
versus social democracies socialism in
the Marxist Leninist sort of tradition
is simply not aligned with the realities
of human distribution because when we
look at human endeavors they have
unequal distribution if you look at
athletic ability and how its distributed
if you look at linguistic proficiency if
you look at business success if you look
at human height human weight it's all
distributed on a curve and on the one
hand where socialism wants to level out
the distribution in a way that I've not
seen evidence can actually be achieved
without significant downsides with
social democracy wants to do is tweak
that distribution lower the app salute
top raise the bottom a little bit and
then reduce the gap between the very
bottom and the very top you're sort of
leveling it out you're raising the mean
and reducing the difference between top
and bottom I think it's important to
look at Sweden as an example the right
hates looking at Sweden Sweden's Social
Democratic Party which I identify with
was built on five principles that will
sound really familiar to Social
Democrats to people who follow Bernie
Sanders and those five principles were
number one an integrative democracy that
means and we can leave this up that
means that democratic decision-making is
the standard for legitimacy period real
democracy the people decide the
direction
number two the concept of the people's
home meaning solidarity and equality of
treatment as something that everybody is
committed to it there's no debate right
you need that number three
socio-economic equality and economic
efficiency are complementary these are
often considered opposing forces by the
capitalists right the the vulture
capitalists which is you can either have
an economically efficient society or one
that is more equal the social democratic
tradition actually sees those as
complimentary number four you have a
socially can
for old market economy and this is huge
it's still a market economy it's still
capitalism but the economy's direction
and the priorities are determined
socially doesn't mean society owns the
means of production as in socialism but
society guides the market economy and v
proper expansion of the public sector
expands freedom and freedom of choice
think about it health care for all
let's people get the jobs that are
actually their passion socialized
education means that people can really
study what they want rather than
deciding on the cheapest career to avoid
student loans this is all in line with
my ideology but it still exists within a
capitalist market economy that allows
for Entrepreneurship and
individualization and all of the good
things that come from the natural
diversity of people now when you talk
about Sweden and you talk to the right
they will try to destroy these talking
points and you've got to know how they
try to do it a popular when one is okay
that that worked in Sweden because
Sweden is homogeneous it's all white
it wouldn't work in a diverse country
this is patently absurd okay
the u.s. is 77 percent white Sweden is
85 percent white okay the idea that
those eight percentage points are what
make a system work in Sweden and not in
the u.s. is absolutely laughable it's
also funny the hypocrisy that many
right-wing or simultaneously claimed
Sweden is being taken over by brown
immigrants and it's chaos but at the
same time
Sweden works really well because
everybody is white that should make
everybody say wait wait a second that
doesn't really make sense
consider the counterpoint if the United
States were all white would the Swedish
model work it's absurd the United States
is huge and with such differences in
education and religion and so many other
things just making the US all white
would not be what either makes or
doesn't make the Swedish system works
now here is where the critique actually
defends social democracy over socialism
a totally socialist society whether
Marxist or utopian or anarchist or
Leninist in the US would actually be
impossible
but what wouldn't be impossible would be
socializing certain elements of American
society health care for example very
doable large countries socialized
healthcare education education could be
put into sort of the umbrella of social
welfare in the United States that's the
Social Democratic model that I support
one other argument from the right which
is they say it works in Sweden because
Sweden is small and the u.s. is big
that's part of why I believe that total
socialism actually is not the path
forward but that there are social Liza
Balcon ponents which would work
absolutely fine in the United States so
to sort of give you the highlights of
why I'm not a socialist and I am a
social democrat I believe that a
socially directed market economy that
reduces income inequality and ensures a
real standard of living for everybody is
more realistic and it's also more in
line with human nature which actually
shows that there is distribution when it
comes to any endeavor that humans get
involved in and I fundamentally and this
gets back to the real reason that I so
vehemently oppose what we see going on
in Venezuela and what we see and have
seen in other places around the world I
do not believe because I've seen no
evidence that an egalitarian
self-determining free society will
develop from an authoritarian apparatus
period I'm willing to change my mind so
let me know your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show and I look forward
to dialogue on this issue going forward
I'm really thrilled to tell you that
today's program is made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman as many
of you know I have been working very
hard on this program to reduce stigma
around mental health to reduce stigma
around seeking help and I have a family
that is very involved in mental health
and if you've not already heard about
better help it is a tremendous resource
better help gives you through your phone
and computer affordable private access
to licensed trained accredited
experienced psychologists counselors
therapists and clinical social workers
who were dedicated to helping you
through whatever is going on in your
life you just go to better help calm
slash Pakman fill out a questionnaire
they will match you with a counselor
that will work best for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over video phone
and text from at home and on the go it
is way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm slash PA que ma N